what was
the pain and the joy and the vision of
the iphone in your mind in the mind of
the team
and steve's mind and so on
well
you know there's multiple pains you have
to also look there's not just customer
pain but there's business pain
okay it's about the so apple now
is getting out of that place where it
was in 2001. now people are starting to
pay attention apple's starting to get in
the culture again it's becoming relevant
cash is starting to flow ipod is 60 of
that
of the
of the revenue total revenue of apple
doing on 85 market share you're starting
to get a win at your back you got
confidence like apple had been beaten
down since probably the first time the
mac was since the mac
it was a beaten company ever since the
mac so we're talking
15 years at that point
right this is the first time you're
seeing likes and steve wood proudly came
in front of us and said
today i can tell you all the employees
we are now out of debt we paid off our
debt
it was a joyous moment
for him
right and then ultimately for our team
because no more debt
it's wonderful right
so now what you have is you have this
successful thing changing the face of
apple
and you hear these
heavy stomping footsteps
of the mobile phone industry
boom
and it's the feature phones at that time
they're adding cameras they're adding
color displays they're seeing the
success of the ipod and going
that's just music we have some storage
we can load music on our phones and we
can do what the ipod does plus more
boom
boom
yeah
right and you're like and how many mil
hundreds of millions of them are being
sold at that point it wasn't billions
yet but it was still you know 100
million 200 million a year
ipod hadn't gotten there it was
4 20 40 50 million something like that
so now you're like okay what are we
gonna do about this you know goliath
who wants to take our lunch right
the schoolyard bully
and so
well there was one let's partner with
them
so itunes music store was there
all of these phones are going to need
music
so
they can come to the itunes music store
and get that music for those phones
because it wasn't just about the
hardware player at that point it was
about the software that you need on the
desktop and the content that you needed
to download so now apple had multiple
legs of the stool as steve would always
refer to it
so now the mobile phone industry okay
we're going to work with them
they are going to make a red an ipod
shuffle basically
inside of a phone can i have 99 songs
total and they're going to come to our
store and you're going to i was like
okay great it's all going to be well and
good and that became the motorola rocker
project
it was
apple motorola getting together there
was going to be software on the on this
smartphone or not smartphone but feature
phone to cook to itunes to get your
music it wasn't even downloadable over a
cloud or anything because that wasn't
available yet there wasn't
data networks yet
um
it was a disaster from the beginning
two different cultures
two different types of leadership styles
uh not necessarily the most competent
engineers on on on on the other side
and it turned out to be an absolute
horrible disaster
i watched the pains because i luckily i
didn't have to be part of i watched the
pains on jeff robin's face each time we
would meet and he would be like
these guys are just you know like
really do we have to do this steve and
he's like we're contractually obligated
and when it came out on stage and steve
showed it it was maybe a one minute you
know steve loves those extended you know
like drawn up it might have been a one
minute two minute kind of thing and he
literally threw that phone out of his
hand as fast as he could yeah right
because it was horrible so that so there
was the pain of we're not gonna partner
so if we can't partner with these guys
we have to become one of them
to actually compete yeah to save the
thing that is bringing apple from you
know that 15 years of malaise
right
so then from that
we were made
a prototype of an ipod plus phone a
classic with um well it was an ipod but
it had a phone inside with all the music
and all the other stuff and you use your
headset
wired headset to do the audio right
there was another project
at the same time because we were doing
videos in the uh the itunes music store
itunes video store
for music videos and movies
and it would be a full screen ipod so
instead of the the classic the way you
know it um it would be full screen and
it would have a virtual click wheel
you'd have a virtual like single touch
touch screen that you could scroll right
think of maybe an i an iphone like you
knew it right and then there was a third
project going on not in those two were
going on in my team but the third
project going on
was the multi-touch screen
technology to drive a uh mac tablet
and so that mac tablet that that
touchscreen technology
um there was just way too much you had
to change on the software and everything
to be able to use a tablet right we see
this all the time like people like
there's not enough tablet apps today
that are modified for tablet they're
just phone apps that are grown up right
so then they would just be mac
touch stuff so you'd have to have a
whole developer community
that probably wasn't the best place to
take that technology first so you take
that technology marry it with the full
screen ipod and the phone stuff we were
working because the ipod phone with the
rotary dial was just like a rotary phone
we couldn't make that interface work
well for data input um you put those
three together and now those were those
those three things that then created the
form
or the technology in the form inside
what would become the iphone
married with a bunch of low-level
software from the ipod and manufacturing
software and drivers and communication
stuff
combined with
a very reduced
frankenstein mac os
and i mean that in the the mess the best
way it means it wasn't mac os just
changed a little it was totally things
were hacked out and changed and think
new code was inserted and it really was
a
a whole set of things from all different
places to make that first iphone os and
then there was another team working on
the apps
and then another team working on the
design of how it looked overall between
all that stuff so all of those things
came together to create what we know as
the first generation iphone and those
are all probably fascinating engineering
challenges correct and great teams like
the creating frankenstein os
that's fascinating because you're
simplifying simplifying but then you're
just pulling different stuff from and
you're basically inventing i mean
they're probably not thinking of it that
way but
a new era of computing a new kind of
computer it really is frankenstein right
and you didn't have to run mac software
if you look at some of the other
smartphones of the time like
windows and stuff they were like we need
to make sure it runs excel and it runs
word or something like that in some
reduced thing this was like no no no no
this was born out of entertainment so we
didn't have to go and take all the same
application you know uh all those other
ones was about compatibility this was
about a whole new way of being
what did you think about
um
the steve jobs presentation of the the
iphone the the sort of
the first iphone
you know phone uh internet communicator
and the ipod in your pocket they're
going to sort of present
announcing three new products
kind of thing and then saying that it's
all in one just this is a good example
one of the sort of
historic
presentations of a product uh
clearly there's like some showmanship
that works some reason it works right it
doesn't always work it often doesn't
work but it did in in this case it often
did for steve what like how did that
feel
um
what part of the actually
uh
the design process
was that presentation
you know what i mean like from the early
because you said for sure so consider
the why the press release at the very
exactly
steve was doing that the entire time he
was working on that story from day one
yeah he was pitching us this this this
and then this and and then he would look
at our faces because you wouldn't most
people wouldn't at least if you're
working for him wouldn't tell him what
you really thought of what he was saying
but he would look at your faces yeah and
then he would talk to a few real trusted
confidence outside of the
uh outside of the organization and see
what they thought right and they could
give him feedback on it and they could
really challenge him but they could he
would also look at their faces and go
and so when you see that
then he would modulate it and change it
slightly and change so he was working
during all of that time on the story and
the storytelling
right and the whys
while we're working on that and helping
us refine it just like the switch from
plastic to glass right
all the time working on that so when he
comes out on stage he does something
that every marketer is told not to do
say these three things are now combined
in one
that is like the that they say that that
is the laziest form of storytelling
possible for marketing
right yeah right but it was the best one
because it was all those panes it was
like i want my ipod but i want my
communications and i want my internet
browsing because i want it on the go so
i can look up things because it was
information
and when you were on the road you had a
laptop you had an ipod and you had a
phone that and you had to carry all of
these things with you at once
now we're going to solve that pain
for you and put it all together so he
was just showing you the pain and
viewing that virus of doubt and going
it's now in this one magical thing
and he could come up and masterfully
tell that story because he told it
almost every day
to all of these people inside very
quietly and then it was just
right it was like a you know a tony
award-winning play that had been worked
on for 10 years but also the human came
through the timing it was all that it
was yeah and of course he was dramatic
at certain points and he would raise his
voice and a wry smile or whatever it was
right
all those touches he was an actor as
well as a storyteller yeah and that but
but it was the truth
right
the truth came through it was a
non-fiction story and then he added
those personal flourishes on top of it
to for dramatic effect
it's amazing
you